hello everyone I just landed in Berlin
yesterday for the very first time in my
life and I've already fallen in love
with this city
sorry there we go so my name is Wei Jing
and I go by Jing as well now I really
love emojis and we have 2666
emojis right now with which to express
ourselves so I'm going to introduce
myself with them so I'm from Malaysia
very proud of that and I used to play
basketball full time basketball actually
helped kickstart my web career so you
can ask me about that later if you're
interested now my in ordinate love of
CSS is what compels me to speak and
write about this topic and it's
essentially what put me here on this
stage in front of all of you today I
also happen to be a Mozilla tech speaker
which is an initiative by Mozilla that
supports Technical Evangelist in
regional communities around the world by
providing resources and funding now what
do you think about when you hear the
word typography it used to be that
typography was a bit of a niche subject
something that only artsy creative types
cared about but these days it seems that
topographic stories have been making
their way into mainstream use we have
big brand names like National Geographic
and Netflix talking extensively about
their phone redesigns the Microsoft font
Calibri by Lucas Nick root was a crucial
piece of evidence that proved the
forgery of financial documents in a
Supreme Court case in Pakistan but what
is
typography now there are plenty of
definitions out there I personally
always refer back to this one by Garrett
nor J that typography is writing with
pre fabricated letters now letters are a
type of grapheme which is the smallest
unit of a writing system of any given
language writing systems are visual
representations of verbal communication
a means to record whatever we say in our
respective languages for storage and
transfer the world is very diverse when
it comes to language and culture so it's
only natural that there are many
different writing systems used all over
the planet
now a majority of the world used writing
systems that consist of alphabets this
is just a really small sampling of
different alphabets from different
languages now the Hebrew alphabet only
has 22 letters the Ukrainian alphabet
slightly larger with 33 letters that's 7
more letters than the English alphabet
which only has 26 now the point I'm
trying to make here is that alphabetic
writing systems utilize a small set of
letters to form all the words a language
needs for the purpose of communication
Chinese a bit different it's a
logographic language now Chinese
characters number in the tens of
thousands and each character is a unique
glyph that can express meaning on their
own or be used in combination with other
glyphs so let's look at a few examples
to illustrate this point the word
communication this is an English word
you'd need 13 letters to spell it
Chinese we can express the same in two
characters we can say gold tongue I'm
gonna butcher this word so please excuse
me German speakers back five fingers ik
this is a German word of eighteen
characters and in Chinese we can say
something really similar we can say
champion green - Oy actor this is an
Irish word I may be pronouncing it wrong
as well but again in Chinese two
characters is enough you can say sure so
Chinese is a pretty concise language if
you ask me and although a large sort of
the world reads mostly from left to
right writing systems can go in all
directions modern-day vertical writing
applies to East Asian scripts that
utilize Han characters so languages like
Chinese Japanese Korean and these are
read from right to left Mongolian also
uses vertical writing but it's
from that direct now Han characters are
sometimes called square characters
because each character is composed with
in a uniform square so this allows
Chinese to be read efficiently
regardless of whether it's typeset
vertically or horizontally now Chinese
text can be typeset into neat rows and
columns and if you don't understand
Chinese you may not know which direction
the text is going it could be vertical
right-to-left or horizontal top to
bottom now the Chinese script is said to
have developed independently from
proto-sinaitic scripts which were the
origins of alphabetic characters so this
is potentially why indo-european writing
systems are inherently different from
those of East Asia as different
alphabetic writing systems branched out
from Phoenicia enough but there are
letter forms evolved and changed the
appearances of letter forms were often
directly influenced by the tools that
were used to create them the earliest
letters were sans-serif when writing was
done with a hard read pen now when the
transition was made to a square cut
implement like perhaps you know flats
dip brush the letters developed serifs
now in the Middle Ages when demand for
written matter kept growing scribes and
copyists who used quill pens had to
develop more efficient stars in writing
so the letter forms evolved yet again
now Chinese characters have to evolved
greatly since the earliest glyphs were
scratched into turtle shells and animal
bones as far back as 1600 BCE
so this earliest script was called
Oracle bone script because the ancient
rulers who used them to consult with the
various higher powers important
questions about things like agriculture
weather warfare things that royalty
cared about the key implement of Chinese
writing is the brush calligraphy was and
still is one of the most highly regarded
Chinese US and the work of famous
calligraphers were used as the basis for
carving what blocks use for printing
which was invented in China but these
days typefaces used for printing Chinese
publications can be broadly classified
into these four families we have song ki
Chi Chi
funk song P and hate so a bit different
from Latin based scripts now Chinese
typefaces
are extremely challenging to create
simply due to the volume of this
required now the average number of
glyphs for a Chinese system font clocks
in at around 35,000 glyphs give or take
a few thousand so this coat is from an
article on courts that cover the process
of creating a Chinese font it is a
pretty interesting read because it goes
into how much effort is needed to design
and create a Chinese typeface now for a
typeface to be viably used as body copy
it will probably need a minimum of 7,000
glyphs if you're using simplified
Chinese or 13,000 glyphs if you're going
for traditional Chinese but that's still
a lot of glyphs hence Chinese fonts are
almost always designed by teams over
periods of years now the web is less
than 30 years old and because it's a
completely new medium it's only natural
that people try to reconcile it with
something familiar like print however
there is an additional degree of
separation between the creator and the
final output as such we cannot have the
same set of expectations when it comes
to handling the web as a medium this is
a medium where you cannot directly
manipulate the canvas in this case the
viewport of my browser instead what we
do is we write code as instructions to
the browser to tell them how we want our
designs to be rendered now with the
release of CSS grid last year it seems
that we've hit yet another milestone for
web design now Jen Simmons creator of
the amazing series layout land you
should really subscribe if you haven't
she drew a parallel between the
evolution from metal letterpress to
photo based pasted up with this
evolution from floats to great modern
CSS gives us a wider vocabulary with
which to communicate with the browser so
we can leverage these new capabilities
that browsers now have for better art
direction more creative layouts and
fresher designs that break out of the
cookie cutter molt were so used to
seeing on the web
now as an athlete I cannot help but draw
parallels between my work and my
experience with my sport CSS is a
holistic technology in that even though
you can use properties in isolation the
full power of CSS shines through
when properties are used in combination
so you can treat this talk like a
scouting report where I profile some of
the most promising players on Team layup
and how they can work really well
together to handle certain situations
but really at the end of the day like
Jackie mentioned earlier you have to
find a solution that best works for your
use case now it was purely by chance
that I started exploring vertical
layouts on the web see I was stuck in a
crowded subway train a few years ago and
I was inadvertently peering over the
shoulder of the guy standing in front of
me and he was reading a Chinese novel on
his phone so it was typeset horizontally
right and I first this is when I first
thought to myself hey a traditional
vertical layout what what really great
on a phone I wonder if this can be done
on the web turns out it can and really
well - so these are websites that have
won the tata yoko webb award which is
given to those who are willing to take
up the challenge of ushering in the next
generation of web typography for
vertical text by designing and utilizing
new typesetting standards with modern
CSS now some of you may find this hard
to believe but vertical text was
supported by Internet Explorer since
version 5.5 oh yes they were using a
much earlier version of the
specification which originated from SVG
now chrome started supporting vertical
text in 2010 it was followed by Safari
in 2011 then opera in 2013 and finally
Firefox in 2015 but although vertical
writing is native to East Asian
languages that doesn't exclude you from
using vertical text simply because you
don't design for those languages if
anything the fact that browsers can now
better support vertical text allows us
to draw design inspiration from more
sources than before for horizontal only
languages you wouldn't want to layout
text vertically for
passages understandably but there's
subtle ways that you can insert vertical
text into your designs to add some
flavor without compromising the reading
experience an example could be labels
for card based designs so popular or
tags for blog posts cases where text is
not critical to understanding the main
content you can even use them for
headers for sections on long scrolling
pages you could perhaps use them for
small screen navigation a lot of
possibilities here but vertically ads
are not a new thing it's just that the
web hadn't reached a level of maturity
that could do them well until recently
take for example this is a mixed layout
multilingual magazine cover from Japan
this is totally doable on the web today
this poster is by Edward McKnight Cofer
one of Europe's most influential poster
artists in the 30s 20s and 30s and he's
already using some vertical text another
one bike offer with some diagonal layout
going on there this one is a vintage
cover of architectural design magazine
with this radial text layer and then I
came across this particular book cover
by Cora Lee Bickford Smith for the
craftsman and I thought okay let's do
pencils specifically let's do these
vertical pencils with text in them on
the web
now while preparing for this talk I got
a bit carried away with the sports
analogy and ended up being sidetracked
by creating CSS trading cards because I
have the attention span of a
five-year-old anyhow let's start off
with something reasonably familiar so in
this case CSS transforms even the
transforms are often used for animation
static transforms can be pretty useful
to my basic strategy was to start off
with an unordered list and each pencil
being a list item then styling each item
to look like metal and then lay them out
vertically so the second and third
points are actually pretty closely
intertwined so the mark-up for this is
very basic
the additional P tag inside this next
item is for styling purposes because I
only have to see you
to play with and that's really not
enough for a pure CSS pencil the K
property for the visual effect we see
here is borders now the border property
in my opinion is an underrated CSS
property if you've read liova rules book
CSS secrets or watched a really
brilliant talk on the humble
border-radius you may already know this
but the tips of the pencils are made
using the CSS triangles technique which
makes use of the fact that borders meet
as diagonals now there are 4 2d
transforms that are available to us and
wheels use the rotate transform to get
the pencils vertical now the tricky part
about using transforms is that you have
to keep in mind the transform origin and
how the browser deals with transforms to
begin with so transforms bring the
element in question into its own layer
and takes it out of the normal document
flow so if you're trying to rotate
elements that are supposed to be part of
a larger layout which is pretty much all
the time you might end up with unwanted
overflows or overlaps now a friend of
mine tried to transform an entire
website and discovered so many
interesting things that it warranted a
20-minute song at our local CSS meter so
what other options do we have for
vertical layouts well the outcome of my
research into types entering Chinese
vertically on the web let me to discover
the existence of the writing modes
specification this specification covers
all sorts of international writing
systems extending and replacing the
unicode BD and direction features in CSS
2.1 it also introduces a number of rules
and properties that are required to
properly support vertical text in CSS so
this is what happens to your text when
different values of writing mode are
applied now the default is horizontal
top to bottom and change the direction
to vertical we use vertical RL or
vertical LR and when we rotate text it's
not only the lines that change direction
because you see each line actually
contains individual letters or
characters and they have an orientation
as well for text orientation the value
of this property
initially mixed because browsers are
smart enough to figure out which
languages can be typeset both vertically
and horizontally or in one direction
only Chinese characters for example will
always be displayed upright while
horizontal only languages like English
or German will have their characters
rotated when vertical so the text
orientation property lets you control
this and make all the characters up
right or sideways if that's what you
want
text combined upright is a property that
addresses the issues of numerals or
abbreviations in vertical text it allows
us to fit them into the width of one
character and display them up right so
no browser supports the last one the
digits value yet this value allows us to
dictate how many digits or letters are
acceptable to be squeezed into this
little space so reasonably the range
allowed is between two to four
characters but for now we only have the
all value there is no limit so you could
put a really long word like I don't know
Beethoven and the browser will do it you
will squish all those letters into that
single character space probably not
something you want but you could always
try it out so back to pencils will keep
the same strategy as before except that
the layout and visual styles are
essentially done together and you'll
you'll see why in a bit no change to the
markup here we apply writing mode first
because presently we still rely heavily
on the physical directions of left right
top bottom when it comes to styling
elements and all the borders that I used
previously they have to be recalibrated
because it's not as straightforward as
taking the styling from the transforms
use case and slap on vertical RL and
call it a day no if you compare the coat
for this and it's a bit lengthy you'll
notice that even though the words are
rotated and flowing from right to left
the direction of margins and padding's
still adhere to our upright perspective
so for example padding on the left of my
pencil text I have to apply it using
padding top and this sort of confuses me
a lot but luckily we have an
up-and-coming new player on Team layout
the CSS logical prop
but it does this it uses logical
properties like block star and block end
and in line stun an inline end which are
relative to the blood flow of the page
allowing us to use the same code
regardless of writing mode I highly
suggest reading Rachel Andrews in-depth
article on CSS on Smashing Magazine to
gain a better understanding of this
relatively new spec in fact the purse
first public working draft of the
specification was published in December
of last year and I'm really eager to see
it developed and more widely implemented
now we can't talk about layout without
talking about flexbox and flexbox is
definitely an all-star player on team
there now if you try to print out the
specification it's about 87 pages long
and there's a very good reason for that
because it defines a new layout mode
designed for laying out complex
applications and web pages it's probably
the first property is specifically
designed to do layout on the web so
let's have more pencils many many more
pencils and I want them to be a mixture
of vertical and horizontal pencils so
this is becoming a larger scale layout
situation and flexbox is capable of
handling this it's it's very versatile
like that you can use it for small
components or a bigger scale layout so
the mark-up is similar to previous
examples just you know multiplied lots
of times now these pencils are a mix of
vertical and horizontal with different
colors so you can see which way they are
being laid out now the cool thing about
sex books is that it can do space
distribution and content alignment like
nothing we've seen before flex children
can be laid out in any flow direction
leftward rightward downwards or even
upwards if that's what you want display
order can be reversed or rearranged
although this does have accessibility
implications and should be used with
caution but items are in the Flex
container are laid up like a long daisy
chain but even if they're wrapped around
there's actually no relationship between
the rows and columns it's just one
really long row or one really long
column that wrapped around itself
so property that controls the flow
direction is aptly named flex direction
and with this we can actually reorder
the flow of content so the default value
is Rho but if I want to reverse it I can
say Rho reverse and you can see based on
the colors that it has changed the way
it's it's flowing and we have another we
have other options as well we can do the
x-direction column and you can see it's
now this way going downward column
reverse makes it go upward so you're not
limited to just left and right which is
actually the title of my talk now again
I want to emphasize that this merely
modifies the visual order and not the
source order of the Flex items screen
readers and keyboard control will still
respect source order now if flexbox
is an all star great is shaping up to be
a Hall of Fame level legend because grid
lets us do a lot of things that were
previously either impossible or highly
untenable now I never talk about grid
without coding Rachel and Rousseau
here's a good one Grint works from the
container in while other layout methods
start with the item so think about how
we done layout in a pre grid error say
we wanted to create a very simple three
column uniform grid when approached for
creating such a layout is with inline
lock so for this you would set the
display of your items to inline block
and give them all a width of a third of
the container it's almost the same views
floats because you also need to set a
width on each item if you use flexbox to
ensure that the items line up in three
columns you have to make sure that the
Flex basis is also a third of the
container the properties were applying
always go on the item so for all three
of the techniques I've just described
there is no grid it just looks that way
because we forced the items to line up
with each other but with grid the grid
is real we define it two rows and
columns then we place items on the grid
wherever we want to we are freed from
the limitation of elements having to
line up next to each other all the time
this means that our layouts can
be canonically non-sequential we don't
have to mess around with absolute
positioning or space or divs or any of
those other workarounds that we used to
do for vertical spacing anymore like
here I have a 6x6 grid with six grid
items
arbitrarily placed anywhere and grid
makes it really simple and intuitive to
have vertical whitespace in our designs
so you essentially just define which row
and which column you want your item to
be it's just coordinate so if you change
the row I can just move that soccer ball
down the grid so it's really intuitive
to have vertical whitespace in our
designs with CSS grid and like I
mentioned there's a lot of great graphic
design that we can draw inspiration from
from for example this is a page from
Lazlo molinaro's book Malory photography
film butchering the pronunciation
brilliantly my say this is a striking
design with bold black borders and
content aligned in different
configurations and if we want such a
design on the web some teamwork will
need to be involved the code Hirsch is a
bridge to show mainly the layout but
even the gear and arrows can be made
with pure CSS it's a box shadow trick
but in order to align the internal
content of each grid child without
disrupting the rendering of those thick
black borders we'll need to make each
grid child a Flex parent so by default
the value of a great items alignment is
stretch where it fills up the entire
space of the grid cell however once you
apply an alignment onto the great items
contents it will shrink to fit the
content now making each grid item of
Flex container allows us to use box
alignment properties to adjust the
position of the great items content
while keeping the boarders at the edge
of the grid another thing that grant
makes a lot easier is overlap we could
have achieved an overlap effect with
absolute positioning but removing an
element from the document flow usually
brings a lot brings about a lot of
unwanted consequences with grid
placement overlap is easily achieved
without disrupting the
stay out at all so this is from another
vintage publication English painter
Charles heaters a new practical treatise
on three primitive colors totally doable
on the web again the code is abridged
but placement is a matter of defining
which row and column you'd like your
element to appear in and how many grid
cells you'd like it to take up it's
perfectly acceptable to have multiple
elements occupy the same space on your
grid so this demo was also an excuse to
play with blend modes CSS blend mode
actually works the same way as in
Photoshop and I learned from the overall
last week that it was Adobe who proposed
the specification for it at this
particular poster for bran is by German
graphic designer and photographer
Wolfgang Mittal it is a rather beautiful
design so no surprises here that such a
design can be done on the web with CSS
script but when we take into account how
dynamic the web is we are designing for
a medium whereby we have absolutely no
control over how our designs will be
viewed things get a little bit more
interesting and it's probably a better
idea to consider aspect ratios over
absolute dimensions when it comes to
designing web layouts and the aspect
ratio media query lets us do that
natively even though the most common
media query we use is with there are 13
media features that are available for
users conditions including height and
orientation somehow we just not seeing
them being used very often on the web at
the moment aspect ratio media queries
are especially useful for designs that
use viewport units but there's no limit
on how you wish to combine multiple
media queries to make your design fully
adaptable now an often raised concern
when it comes to using the newer CSS
features especially those for layout is
browser support because you know nobody
wants the site to look broken that's
legit so here is where feature queries
come in and Oliver who's coming up after
me is gonna go into a lot more detail so
I'm just doing a like brief preview to
warm you up for his talk
this is how a future query looks like
the conditional checks if the browser
supports a particular property or not if
it doesn't the entire block within the
app supports rule is ignored this means
that we start off with a basic layout
that works everywhere then we layer on
Styles based on the features we want to
use by organizing our code in this
manner the browsers that do not support
feature queries all the specified
property will still get styled and those
that do get a different look so we're
making use of the C in CSS so this image
was the header for a CSS tricks article
and it caught my eye you know because it
was diagonal and really nice-looking it
looks almost exactly the same when
recreated in HTML and CSS almost with
feature queries you can do quite a lot
of things for example you can display a
message informing users that a feature
is not supported with pseudo elements
and having a fallback for this
particular example it's just an image
for IE 11 but more often the future
query will contain code that acts as an
enhancement to a design that works in
all browsers and there's nothing
stopping you from using feature queries
and media queries in combination to
cater for different browsers on
different devices with feature queries
we don't have to revisit our codebase to
rewrite things when a browser gets
updated because the code is not browser
specific its feature specific and once a
feature gets shipped your design will be
updated automatically this example makes
use of a combination of feature queries
for both grid and CSS shapes so if
you're on a legacy browser you'll get a
simpler design but everything is styled
on the very left for now Firefox users
in the middle they don't get to see the
CSS shapes yet but once they do the
layout will automatically look like what
Chrome users see at the moment on the
right it used to be that a new feature
or bug fix would take a long time to
shape and that was true in the earlier
days where browsers were updated maybe
six months every six months but these
days the upgrade cycle has shortened
immensely this is probably not the best
data visualization you
Essene but the point I'm trying to make
here is that browsers are being updated
fast and furious these days my favorite
example to talk about is the release of
CSS grid now most major browsers shipped
it in March last year by October 75% of
users around the world were using a
browser that supported grid today that
number 87 percent how amazing is that
it's so much easier to get enthusiastic
about new CSS features these days
because they ship and become more widely
supported so much quicker now and the
same goes for bug fixes every major
browser engine has a pretty open process
for raising bugs and raising bucks for a
particular feature sends a signal to
browser vendors that developers want to
use this feature this encourages them to
prioritize related bug fixes it's a win
for everyone by taking the time to
submit a bug report you gain comma
points you get your bugs fixed and you
make the work better for all of us
so that's it for me and I just wanted to
round off by saying that you don't need
to use any of these techniques or
properties I covered if they don't fit
your use cases today but know that when
the time comes they'll all be right here
waiting for you thank you all for your
kind attention
[Music]
[Applause]